hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to show you a math card trick
that's called red and black piles
start out with the deck of cards that
we're going to mix well
we're going to split the deck into piles
of pairs of cards at a time
if the two suits are red and black we're
going to discard that pair
if the two suits are both red we'll put
it in the red pile
similarly if the two suits are black
we'll put it in the black pile
we're going to go through the entire
deck
and split each pair of cards into either
the discard pile the red pile or the
black pile
at some times it'll look like there'll
be a lot more red cards
other times there'll be a lot more black
cards
at the very end we'll do a count of the
number of cards in each pile
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12.
let's see how many are in the black pile
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12. this is
quite interesting the red and black
piles have an even number of cards even
though it seemed like we mixed the deck
up
and at times some of the piles had
different numbers than others
is this just a coincidence well let's do
it again
we'll separate the deck
into three different piles
red black in the discard pile now let's
do count one two three four five six 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
and in the black pile 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16.
again we have the same number of cards
in the red pile as there were in the
black pile
in fact the two piles will always be the
same
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can also
support me at patreon you'll get
exclusive rewards
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions on twitter at preshtalwalker
or get my books at amazon